Have you heard of high dose melatonin for cancer, like two hundred and ten milligrams?
Yes, and I do write about that in the stock fighting cancer book.
And it can be beneficial.
So, yes, it's, you know, necessarily if most of the writings don't say that they go up to two hundred and ten milligrams.
It's anywhere between 60 milligrams and maybe two hundred milligrams.
But most people at our doing high dose melatonin might be doing like 80 to a hundred milligrams.
That's the average.
We do have a 20 milligram melatonin capsule in our store.
It's hard to find the high dose melatonin capsules.
It's not very expensive.
It's something that some people are bad and doesn't test.
There are typically people who don't have a lot of people on that protocol.